let's jump into the first big news
from timcast.com
biden admin has suspended the
disinformation governance board the
board's executive director nina
jankowicz announced her departure from
the department of homeland security so
um
just right off the bat it was a terrible
idea i don't think he's doing this
because of free speech i think it's
polling poorly among democrats bill
maher came out on his show and said
these are not bright people in
government so when you get bill maher on
his show to a million liberals saying
this is bad
don't be surprised then when they're
like oh we got a midterm coming up and
we're losing well wait i mean how do we
know this is true or not if biden
suspended the disinformation board
we do know it in fact there was a
question about it today in the white
house press conference with the new
press secretary corinne jean-pierre
peter ducey asked if perhaps the
disinformation governance board was
suspended due to disinformation
well there we go and without a
government support how would we know
yeah
john pierre basically confirmed that yes
there was uh
misinformation surrounding the
disinformation governance board that a
lot of people had slammed it it's the
perfect crime it's the perfect crime
yeah that a lot of people had slammed it
um it was actually pretty amazing to see
this come down today uh that's
misinformation i don't believe it no i
mean that seriously that they were like
oh you know people were spreading lies
about it so we had to shut it down no no
no no no it was it was obviously not
lies it was obvious that people were
spreading truth about it in fact the
head of the ministry of truth the
minister of truth nina jankowicz uh had
spread substantial amounts of
misinformation all by herself on her own
feeds and it was spectacular because as
soon as she was announced as soon as she
came out on twitter and announced that
this is what she'd been working on for
the last seven months jack posobik went
out there and just started pulling all
of her old tweets and all of her old
things where she was talking about
russia collusion and all of these things
uh covered things and she was like just
spreading misinformation and
disinformation all over the place you
know what i really hope her and james
lindsey end up in a musical together
yes did you guys see her singing okay
people were like making fun of i was
like dude make fun of her for the
misinformation don't make fun of her for
singing yeah well the the political
singing was real cringe
when she did the mary poppins political
thing i was like come on come on come on
come on come on i didn't know what are
we doing here
but the actual you know she got ragged
on by the caller i defended her when she
was doing that what do i got to do to be
famous bit i'm like yeah it was good ian
i said i thought her singing was good
because it's not political she was just
doing a bit and she was like i want to
be famous
and then ian was like no she's got her
shoulders up and tight she's not singing
from the chest she doesn't know what
she's doing and i'm like which is
hilarious because like usually ian goes
easier on people even when they say
things politically that we very much
disagree with but she she's singing
wrong he's like no this is absolutely
not like
he took theater yeah exactly so he was
like i am offended by this like that's
his area i studied theater for pretty
much my entire life and i actually
thought that it was kind of cute that
she was
into doing performance art even though
she had this weird government career i
didn't have an issue with the uh with
that singing i did have one i did have
an issue with her
covered misinformation mary poppins song
i thought that was total trash it's it's
weird how when uh when we were young the
adults who were writing books about this
stuff when we weren't even alive the
books that were coming out were like the
future dystopia
men have steel jaws from the war and
metal limbs and cyborgs rule all and the
government comes and bangs a giant sword
on the ground do as you're told and what
we really got was this permanent child
who's singing mary poppins going we're
gonna block your news
and it's like it's it's substantially
creepier
you know millennials aren't growing up
no but they don't want to and in part
millennials aren't growing up because
adults have told them that adulthood is
bad we come up with words like adulting
as though there's some problem with
responsibility and it's like just grow
up be responsible why it's not bad the
thing too is it's like when you were a
kid remember when you were a kid and
everyone wanted to grow up i don't know
if you guys had that and people were
like oh i could buy all the toys i want
i'll get to eat all the candy that i
want and it's like now we just yeah you
do get to do that i mean it turns out
you do like i buy ice cream and i put it
in my
fridge and then we eat it when i was
when i was like uh 20 i just one day was
like you know what's one thing i always
thought i would do never did i'm gonna
go to the store and buy a whole thing of
cookie dough just walk around eating it
nice so i went to the grocery store i
grabbed a thing of cookie dough i bought
it started eating it and some little
kids saw me and he went
as he walked as i was as i walked faster
it gets better and i'm like i looked and
i was like hey i'm like that's right i
bite it and then five minutes later i
went oh
like this is why my parents said you
don't do these things
by the way i meant james o'keefe not
james lindsay i'm so sorry i'm not james
that doesn't make any sense yeah unless
you're talking about like his sword
movement yeah no james lindsay would
never be in a musical no maybe no they
wouldn't allow it that's funny because i
pictured james o'keefe when you said
james yeah because i knew that he had
done the things all about musical
theater that would be funny too because
she like
the left thinks james o'keefe is just
like the king of disinformation and
manipulation and the right calls nina
jacob wicks the minister of truth so
like i think what we have right juliette
with james o'keefe
what we have is a broadway show like
what we need is investors that's all we
need this would sell this would sell out
how much do we need i'll fund it right
like what do we need for a broadway show
like uh start with half a million
something done let's see it so here's my
my serious question though is when you
look at the dhs disinformation board and
you look at nina jankowicz they
literally put a child in charge of a of
the department of homeland security and
the issue is the adults
people who are more mature and more
understanding aren't in these jobs
well what they did was they put a fool
in charge of the department of homeland
security they put myorkis in charge and
he came out shortly after biden was
inaugurated and said to immigrants all
across the world we're not saying don't
come we're saying don't come now. and
then he proceeded to deny that repeat
repeatedly that he had said it and he
did say it and he did mean it and that's
that's why we have so many people
storming the border yeah i got a good
idea for a cartoon you could do seamus
yeah i actually is this about biden
saying
okay it is the disinformation board
announcing their shutting down and then
all the journalists are like writing it
down and they're like breaking news and
as they're doing it nina jankowicz
presses a button and then the whole
stage like goes down into a sub base
where it's like they walk into the
generals like we've increased your
funding by three billion dollars and so
the whole thing was just this
information no they're going the
misinformation board's going out of
business all our misinformation has to
go misinformation 20 off all this
information
that's clever i like that and then you
highlight nina jankowicz's uh tweets and
the things she said oh my god it's funny
because when she said that thing about
uh the laptop she's like joe biden says
50 different people said this was like
it was clearly disinformation or
misinformation whichever one you want to
pick
and she was like i was just quoting the
president it's like okay so by your
standard you are spreading
disinformation thank you did you correct
it no i mean was that an excuse if trump
said something that was adjudicated to
have been false by the fact checkers
could you say i was just repeating what
the president said well not this
information actually as you know
whenever trump would make a claim and
the media called him a liar he would
just say well that would have that's
what i was talking about
and the media would go oh
we got it we'll retract that like trump
we have to trump was in fact told that
he was that actually it's a funny thing
what if a journalist you know donald
trump said
uh you know this this will cost x amount
of dollars and they're like how does
that make sense that's not true well
that's what i was told so what
journalist actually investigates and
they find the person who told trump that
and they're like fact check true donald
trump was told this it was corn pop they
formed an alliance yeah
i'm trying to understand who this was
originally angled to try to appeal to in
the budget administration was the msnbc
liberals i don't understand do you think
it was to appeal to anyone or do you
think it was just to try to shut people
up well what they were actually trying
to do if you look at what their
documentation says in the first place
their goal was to dispel disinformation
outside of the u.s
um
russian disinfo right no no like about
immigration and stuff so months and
months ago the white house press
secretary
jensachi had talked about how one of the
biden administration's plans to get
people to stop trying to come to the u.s
illegally was to
give proper information in those locales
to tell them like actually don't come so
i think this was part of that effort
that was sort of the idea but there's so
little goodwill for the biden
administration at this point uh they
spread all kinds of ridiculous
misinformation and disinformation um
that coming out with something like this
there would they had no chance it
doesn't you know if they had come out
and said uh this is part of our
plan to get immigrants to not come to
the u.s we're going to tell them not to
come and gave it some sort of name like
that it would have been much better
received
uh i think because
a lot of people would like there to be
more security at the border yeah well i
mean their entire regime depends upon
spreading misinformation right when they
came out and they were saying things
like the reason we have higher prices is
because store owners are greedy right
and it's putin's fault that we have high
gas prices i mean joe biden said
that to tackle inflation we're going to
make the corporations or what do you say
who makes the rich make the rich pay
more taxes and then peter ducey was like
how does making rich people pay more
taxes lower inflation well that counters
all of their arguments about how rich
people they also say rich people don't
stimulate spending they just hoard all
the money so i find that logic taxing
them could never curb my favorite is
that joe biden launched his campaign off
of misinformation and also they wanted
to charlottesville yeah they sure did he
sure did and written house and
everything he lied about that not to
mention that he's run before he the
charlottesville ever happened
he's lied all the time and he's
plagiarized everything yep and he's
gonna come out and be like i'm gonna
tackle this information
i came up with that and then you're like
there's a guy standing next to him was
like writing it down and he's like i
guess
yeah it's pretty sad it's pathetic it's
just that this is a regime which
repeatedly says things that are
verifiably untrue i mean we're not just
talking about a situation where someone
might be using facts which are true to
construct a narrative that we disagree
with like saying that businesses are
raising their prices just because of
corporate greed is an unbelievably
insane and easily falsifiable thing to
say
did businesses just get greedy after we
flooded the economy with extra money
yes oh okay well never mind i've been
fact checked they're all greedy yeah
they're super greedy that's why they're
that's why they're trying so hard to
hire people yeah well and then
offering all of these signing bonuses to
do so and what's fascinating to me is
like they just became greedy after a
bunch of money was injected into the
economy like that's when they decided to
become greedy and raise prices
interesting also it's interesting that
the
binding administration is currently
looking to
reduce sanctions on venezuela in order
to
gain oil exports from that country
as though venezuela is some perfectly
fine place like why did we have
sanctions they haven't made any changes
it's just that we want their stuff
and same with saudi arabia if it was
donald trump i think we would have been
able to get something out of the saudis
but might be a whole other conversation
yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there